So let's look at what the code for
this would look like with a quick
walk-through some of the pieces.
You'll need to do something similar
later using the documentation
as a guide.
Imagine we need to transmit number of
steps detected on an Android Wear device
to a paired up phone.
Let's open up the MainActivity.java
file contained
in the wearable project we just created.
So it's in the wear directory
> java > MainActivity.
The data API is provided
by Google Play Services, so
we need to first create
a connection to this API.
Note that this does not
connect to the wearable,
it just allows your app to make
Google Play Services API calls.
So, after we put this code in,
we need to hit Alt + Enter a few
times to add the necessary packages.
We also need to create a variable
to store the connection in.
And we also need to implement two
classes that are part of GoogleApiClient
for handling connection success and
failure.
So let's provide the implementation for
those methods here.
We don't have any code to put in them,
so let's just leave them blank for now.
Now, let's look at the code
used to create a data item.
Let's create a method send step
count that does this for us.
We firstly create a PutDataMapRequest
and we need to specify a path for it.
The path shown here is used
to reference this object and
make it unique compared to all
the other once that we can create.
Next we use put methods to add
an integer and long key value pair.
We then use putDataItem to submit the
object, and then we need to check for
errors with the callback
to find underneath.
Error handling is very interesting,
because it just indicates that the
object was successfully stored locally.
It does not tell you if the object
was received by remote device yet.
It is totally okay for the remote
device to not even be connected.
When the device connects, the data
item will be synchronized later on.
So you'll never receive feedback that
the remote device has received it.
If you need this kind of feedback,
you'll need to code up some kind
of feedback mechanism yourself.
Another analogy for this is that
a package delivery company giving you
an acknowledgment that
the package has been collected.
It has not been delivered
to the recipient yet and
might take some time to get there.
One important point is that data items
are promised to never be lost and
will eventually arrive once
the other device is paired up.
Let's now look at the receiving
code on the phone.
So let's expend the project viewer,
and work in the mobile project now.
On the receiver side it's quite easy
to find when new data items arrive,
you simply create a service for this.
So let's go to File > New > Service.
Create it with all the defaults,
and then hit Enter.
The first thing we need to do,
is make sure it inherits from
WearableListenerService and
add dependencies.
You can also remove the entire
implementation because we're
going to replace it.
You then override
the onDataChange method,
which is past an array of data
events that have occurred.
For each DataEvent object you
can retrieve the DataMap,
and then extract out the path and
values for each key from before.
You can see here that we're looking for
a change, we're then extracting
out the path, we're testing if
the path equals a certain string, and
then we pull out the integer and long
value to do whatever we want with it.
The final step is to adjust
the AndroidManifest.xml on the receiving
side to make sure our listener service
handles the BIND_LISTENER intent.
Google Play Services will then handle
all the necessary behind the scenes work
to get the data items to your listener.
You don't need to start
the service itself.
So let's expand the project and
open up the AndroidManifest.xml file.
The final step is to adjust
the AndroidManifest.xml on the receiving
side to make sure our listener service
handles the BIND_LISTENER intent.
Google Play Services will then handle
all the necessary behind the scenes work
to get the data items to your listener.
You don't need to worry about
starting this service yourself.
Oh, and one more thing.
Let's go back to the sending code and
talk about large items.
Data items are typically
limited to about 100 KBs.
So make sure you do
not exceed this size.
However, if you need to send
something like an image,
it's possible using the Asset class.
You convert you bitmap into
a png byte stream, and
then store it into a data
item using putAsset.
This deals with sending the image in a
way that works around the 100 kB limit.
So that's it for sending data items.
The fundamentals are really easy and
most of the hard work like handling
the connections and sending the data
is all taken care of for you.
So you can focus on the important
parts of your app instead.